hello and welcome to this video play p
ed from denmark so let's see what we get
is conch game clock playing my old line
here but good wood or something yeah i
know it's it's something that is on my
should be replaced list but i'm still
not scoring with it so badly they're
just like 10 29 said I feel arm I really
am yeah really asking too many questions
that I don't have clear answers do and
this is I think not that critical this
Queen g4 idea that has been played by
Kasparov actually so it has a great
stamp of approval but I think nowadays
it's not considered to be that dangerous
there is also Knight f6 which is quite
good but I don't know it all that well
and when I studied this I came to the
conclusion that what I'm playing at the
moment here is also ok let the Queen to
g6 that Quincy 326 should be a
satisfactory for black the Ignite have
six is much more aggressive but um I
wasn't totally sure about some things
when I looked at it some time ago and
this is I mean okay it's an ending if he
takes but this is still an ending where
there is some potential conflict going
on yeah it's not like completely boring
or anything like that I actually even
don't mind him getting the bishop pair
because look at the root zone you got
get to active looks so
however and Bishop a6 trade one of the
roofs off could be interesting not sure
can also do this right I could play like
c5f 6g 595 there just to put the night
on a good square mmm this one
immediately maybe ships you form traded
like that maybe try to provoke f4 yeah
I'm not sure if this is actually
something that I should provoke but it
gives some ok it doesn't doesn't go for
it but this now I think I'll trade this
and put the night on c4
you
hey just say that's an interesting
interesting ending here take it nicely
form ok so and see what to do this is a
nice p 7c wallet I'm not entirely sure
how I'm going to make any progress in
this ending and probably there's nothing
much to do on the edge fun I could try
try to play I mean b3 it's never really
something great I go Knight a5 and he
has just created more weaknesses so
maybe i can double on the e-file and
then play a 545 let's see now I mean he
always has always has ok he plays it so
this provocation somehow worked yeah I
was thinking that this is good for me
because the a porn is a weakness so I
can best basically bring the looks back
now and play against CA porn here we go
so going to play a 4
I'm going to do this yet wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait it's got King III in
some cases
hmm ok I can also click insist sex maybe
this is correct and the hill then he has
a form maybe b5 King do thinking see
success that that that seems to be okay
I still ask all day for ah ah chess is a
tricky game sometimes yeah I was more
concerned about King King be 30 I just I
just didn't see this one haha ok Oh
fantastic really great now I didn't see
this I Piero how stupid and white
already wasn't some trouble to be honest
i gotsta feel stupid completely
unnecessary so am i i'm just piling up
there I think on on the avon the a porn
shouldn't overlook some some silly
tactic again why I mean you didn't place
the detector you know I mean just
something concrete
so might be okay for me at least that
I'm not worse no I don't really see
anything good that he can try isn't he
playing for loss here giving me the
apron I'm kind of surprised here I mean
he doesn't have time to play be savin or
stuff like that I don't see this
happening a3 is really quick this bond
check white resides ok I was a bit
luckier i have to have blundered this
pawn so yeah let's join join the action
somewhere here so we have this yakety q4
here right yeah i don't like to take
those pawns it often leads to problems
in the in the original game because far
off the black player also took on d4 it
was WindSeeker actually in one of his
last games and had no I just let that
just develops tough and then I'm pretty
okay with this with this kind of
situation here night b5 King dat looks a
bit I can take this the right key 8 yeah
this is playable it's not so bad it's
also bad there was a game I think with
Carlton s black penis with a similar
thing gets the job off ok so here I'm
quite happy with this
I think this is a case where the engine
is a bit too optimistic here because
blacks position is really extremely
compact and difficult to to do much ok
now the evaluation is going somewhat
down 0.4 or something I can kind of
accept but I don't think why this is
usually better what did you do it took
it yeah this is this is this is helping
me it's quite clear f3 yep this is
definitely better than taking but do I
really have to capture on the form yeah
maybe 9 p-5 is this is such a problem
eric here but you just the engine just
place the pollution it always wants to
check on before I don't quite understand
where this will help me I mean it
totally changes the structure and then
with with d5 yeah so don't like it yeah
ok but after the capture I'm also ok
according to the money to the machine
here onion equal ish after Bishop c4 I
shall be a bit better right to d3 yet of
course that's and that's an alternative
but here here this is ok I mean the
light squares are nice and I'm
reasonably okay with what I did aren't
you here and have to be more precise now
engine go see fire
yeah played this one and now I should
take okay yeah I can still go to h5 ya
too I just didn't see it I just didn't
see the blot that the bond gets lost
yeah at least the computer agree said
I'm not much worse it's just like in
this point is so where so much of a
problem but what he did now this is this
a for the sistas gives me the advantage
I mean you should I think just stay like
Bishop see one so that whenever I take
here and we actually trade the night
against the bishop and that's this very
draw much I think now the computer
actually give widen advantage that
that's possible so if you're probably
some dry Luke ending but white will
never lose and and distances this is
getting trickier quite quite quickly
before slowly roll up and after this I'm
definitely winning you know making it
true maybe things are already already
gone cook a six what a mysterious move
Oh see I don't know what this move is
doing why do I need to go to a 6 of all
places for just do this and I don't have
a clean I have this ok 44 the King March
yes that's good yeah and something like
this is going to be lost I think ya can
see to clean see form its to a winning
ending ok guys thanks for watching